[Music]
it's been two weeks since our last
episode of the masked singer but we're
back with 11 performers and two
surprising unmasking xym Deidre Behar
and I'm Charlie O'Keefe sadly tonight
our penguin performer got the cold
shoulder from the competition take a
look at the first elimination
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Sherri Shepherd finally I feel like
Jenny McCarthy especially has been
manifesting this one for a long time
nothing I love seeing more than two
women who are friends getting to be on
the same set together a really fun like
girl power moment Jenny's getting her
guess right from last season to this
season I'm finally sherry did a nice job
Jenny
but the penguin wasn't the only
performer to be revealed the Black Widow
isn't spinning her web any longer take a
look
[Applause]
Ravin part one Iver Archie to Grover
Union correct we have been manifesting
this literally since episode 1 a mission
1 out of 2 right now I really can't say
enough great things about Raven this
girl she performs she was getting down
to doing her moves I think it's like
2020 is gonna be a huge year for Raven
and this was a perfect way to kick it
off and I want some of those covers that
she did on the song release Spotify
anything yeah come on boot it up so of
course here on et online we do an
amazing really empowering show called
unfiltered and we recently had raven on
now if you were paying attention to
ravens clues you saw in the clue package
tonight she actually had a banner that
said misdemeanor I was really confused
by it but thankfully unfiltered has your
back
here's what we're even had to say about
Missy Elliott I did a rap album Missy
Elliott wrote my single called
bats little girl's Amita and just
because it's cute here are Ravens item
clues crackers and whipped cream
explains who needs rich crackers in your
house we still have nine more performers
to see first up a singer who has us all
barking for more take a look at the
Rottweiler
[Applause]
[Music]
that voice gets me every single dance
moves the performance every time yeah so
we are watching the show along with you
at home and we love reading your
comments a lot of people who watch this
show seem to think it's chris daughtry i
100% tip my hat to you i now think this
is for sure chris daughtry so watching
the clue package there were three kind
of random names i took to the google and
i tried to figure out what they could
mean so we saw carolina lil pete and
kale so carolina chris daughtry is from
north carolina lil pete his father's
name is Pete Peter and Cale I was like
where is Pete
what does Cale have to do with anything
well if you follow chris on instagram
this guy has really undergone such an
incredible health transformation over
the last year I think it would explain
the incredible ABS on the Rottweiler but
you know kale healthy eating I feel like
it's part of his new lifestyle I'm all
for the kale clue but I want more I just
don't think Carolina his dad and kale
are enough for me Charlie it should be
enough for you okay but the ABS also the
ABS also from the kale but still I need
a little bit more they also mention
musical theater and makeup I don't know
if this has something to do with this
past maybe high school middle school if
you did musical theater and also a
football trophy I couldn't find anything
about that but if anyone knows please
let us know yeah please please say this
below in the comments but I'm still
staying true to my kale hard-hitting
theory this has got to be Chris Daughtry
the ladybug brought some pop to the
stage tonight take a look at this juicy
performance
[Music]
what do you think I'm still stuck on
Kelly yeah me too
Kelly Osbourne all the way that's what I
wrote you know I thought it was a really
funny moment in this episode where they
the kind of guest is it Lindsay Lohan
which we've heard before too right but
this week the ladybug was kind of not
having it she was putting her hands on
her hip she was just like shaking her
head no and we know that Kelly and
Lindsay Lohan have had a friendship in
the past that kind of you know they kind
of have gone their own separate ways at
this point so I could understand why
there's maybe no love lost between the
two of them and maybe the ladybug
doesn't want to be thought of as Lindsay
Lohan um so that was one big clue that I
kind of was tuned into the other thing
that I think makes it Kelly
is that this performer seems to be
nervous Robin Thicke has pointed out the
hands on the stomach she's talked about
in her clue package that this was
actually the first time that she felt
kind of free on stage Kelly hasn't
released new music since 2005 so it
would kind of work in that in that
argument that you know she hasn't been
on stage she hasn't performed in front
of a group of people in a long time so
maybe that's where the nerves are coming
yeah and I thought one of the clues that
was supposed to throw us off in the
package they said pieces of me which is
obviously an Ashley Simpson song and we
actually had Nicole guess Ashley Simpson
but I'm not believing these flu packages
all the way anymore no they're doing too
many red herrings they're just saying
something to make us believe something
else and in my humble opinion that is
not an Ashley Simpson voice that is for
sure a Kelly Osbourne voice I agree up
next we have the Christmas tree who had
us all stumped yet again check it out
I'm lost
lost and truly lost realized we've
pulled the office here some people think
it's Darlene love my best guess is still
somebody whose quote Christmassy like a
Lacey Chabert or possibly even this week
I started to maybe think a Lea Michele
okay
I thought the voices kind of sounded
similar and Lea Michele just put out a
Christmas album last month so it's like
okay she has something to promote and
she obviously loves the holiday so much
but this is in my opinion the absolute
hardest one on the show and I think the
personality makes sense with Lea Michele
true she's fun she's bubbly she's
dancing up there she's kind of playing
with the judges a little bit right but
this is someone who has a food
endorsement of their a brand ambassador
for a food brand and we heard the word
elf so I don't know that's again a red
herring where it's like oh they want us
to think it's maybe Zooey Deschanel but
we know that's definitely not Zooey
Deschanel's really not Zoe's voice yeah
for a second thought Amy Sedaris oh
that's a good guy yeah the cooking the
food at home with Amy Sedaris obviously
she has as well yeah I found some clips
of her singing it doesn't quite sound
like her voice to me though yeah I I
would have to go back and listen to my
Amy Sedaris tapes in order to match
those up it's truly this one has been no
pun intended
really something means something else
and actually Rachael Ray has been one of
the biggest guesses online exactly and
she addressed it last week on her show
when dr. drew former math singer
contestant was also there take a lesson
I wanted to ask you what it was like to
be on the masked singer because
everybody in America swears that I'm on
it
you are rocking that Eagle outfit baby
oh my gosh you look good and feather it
is so embarrassing
[Applause]
the picture it was was it fine he was
fine he was a lot of fights a great
production as well never be brave enough
it's alright
I mean look even if it was she would
have to deny it everyone has to do on
these new shows when they get asked
they're not allowed to say if it's them
truly I don't think it's Rachael Ray I'm
still sticking with my guns I'm going
Lacey Chabert or Lea Michele anyone
anyone but Rachael Ray correct per usual
the flower was in full bloom listen to
these insane vocals
patti labelle okay it's queen patti
rossabi it's got to be one of the most
iconic voices of our entire generation
this woman can just sing she could sing
the alphabet the phone book like you
mentioned earlier you want a cover of
that song on Spotify I want Patti's
cover of this song on Spotify I thought
she sounded so incredible if we want to
take it to the clue package she said
never taking never taken a singing
lesson Patti told The Wall Street
Journal in 2017 I've never taken a
singing lesson I just practice with my
broom I think that's sweet like a
throwback to the beginning of her career
before she became this incredible diva
icon the other big clue that I noticed
was the number five to four I was like
what is this significance what does it
mean well don't look any further than
her birthday Patti was born on May 24th
so I think that all kind of aligns right
and her final clue was her favorite band
is Kings of Leon which Patti LaBelle
Kings of Leon like where do those rank
tied together I would never pin them at
the same place well they actually
performed together at the 2017 Orleans
Jazz Festival so that's where she got
acquainted but there's a connection
there they're friends now love it I do
you have to say I think we cracked the
case on this one so I brought you a
special tree oh my god what did you do
it is none other than miss Patty's sweet
potato pies this is incredible we said
we have to try them did you get this
last night coworker of the year I am so
excited can we take a bite yeah of
course
and as we enjoy Patty's pie we do
actually need to listen to a clip of
Patti trying to say it's not her on
radio Andy Oh Patti
everyone says you're the flower on the
mast singer I promise you everybody said
it was a bee last year oh really
yeah it was the bee was Gladys yeah was
glad yep now if Gladys did it last year
he kind of makes sense she would have
maybe opened the door for someone of
your caliber be on little masks and
supplicate no way the way it looks
it looks like it's hard to breathe and
stuff yes bond Miss Patti did it right
Miss Patti an entrepreneur legend we
stand we stand she can sing and make
pies correct I will be serving this at
Thanksgiving this year at my house you
can take this one out tonight thank you
oh my gosh well no we need something
fresher yeah Thanksgivings in a few
weeks back to miss patty you know she's
a she's an entertainer knows how to put
it on she knows how to deny it I don't
buy that for once I don't buy it for one
second and it's just like we've heard in
other people as well I mean Adrian
tonita as the Flamingo right I still
think it's miss patty
they're contractually obligated to deny
it miss patty we're on to you but we
love your pie hmm so there's no doubt
that the Fox has made it but hey look ma
we're still confused take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope you don't mind I'm gonna keep
eating who are you feeling for the box
my best guest this week after really
sinking in those clues is Leslie Odom
jr. okay
Broadway performer definitely has the
stage presence out there correct what do
you got I want to say Jamie Foxx okay
Wow it's a little ironic being the Fox
Yas Jamie Foxx but I feel like there
were some clues that pointed to him also
he's a performer he can sing I wouldn't
doubt him being on that stage I wouldn't
doubt him being on that stage except I
would here's the thing Jamie is known to
be doing like I don't know anywhere
between like 2 & 5 movies at any given
moment yeah and it's the holidays he's
such a family man I think he's probably
gearing up to maybe enjoy the later part
of his year I don't necessarily think
he'd be willing to get back on the press
train and do interviews about doing the
master singer I don't think that this is
the time and place for it
hear me out ok he has a show on Fox
called beat Shazam we heard the words a
min a clue yeah superhero movies there's
some Jamie Foxx clues here I'm not
ruling it out yeah ok I hear you but I'm
gonna tell you why I don't agree with
Merritt this show is so proud of the
fact that they have so many celebrities
who have earned awards throughout their
career you know if they had an Oscar
winner like Jamie Foxx but that would be
at the absolute top of the list at every
promo they say we have one Oscar what
Oscar what we would hear Oscar all day
long okay
and the fact that we didn't hear that we
have an Oscar winner on this season it
makes me automatically rule out Jamie
all right let us know if you think it's
Jamie Foxx girl Leslie Odom jr. or
someone else there's a million other
options here as well 100% I just think
it's Leslie Odom jr. because he's he's
such a amazing celebrated theatre
performer and he talked a little in the
clue package about how he was ridiculed
for that growing up but it wound up
becoming his biggest superpower it kind
of makes sense I think the boys also
sounds really similar I agree and like
Nicole this is my favorite performer
week after week as well check out the
thingamajig serenading the audience yet
again
[Applause]
I know I originally said Wayne Brady I
am officially changing my vote this has
got to be NBA star Victor Oladipo there
were a lot of messages about shoes in
the clue package and Victor is actually
the spokesperson for finish line so I
think that makes sense it makes sense
and now we are finally getting to the
item clues these are my favorite part of
the season it kind of gives us a glimpse
something a little bit more revealing
than them talking about a song or
something else in the clue package so
for this one we had a sign language book
an ASL book and Victor actually his
sister Kendra lost her hearing when she
was in second grade and he spoke in an
interview about how important it was to
learn sign language to communicate with
her he's a good soul that's a big sign
to me yeah yeah I love that it touches
my heart and I would like to see him win
this show I agree I think it's the voice
Bret and up next it's another sparkling
performance from the shining butterfly
take a look
what we've said this since day one and
we're sticking with Michelle Williams
more proof tonight we got to see a
nurses hat and a certificate from a car
salesman and actually those are the
professions of her parents so did you
find that honey we've got we've got
access to things here at entertainment
tonight her parents jobs were finding
out there they're on her Wikipedia page
what do you think I'm going with the
forensic kit on this one it was her item
and I thought it was a revealing clue
the butterfly did mention that she had
the choice to choose life or death
Michelle has obviously been very open
about her contemplating suicide and
being in rehab and depression so I think
this could kind of lean towards that
yeah and I think it's so incredible that
she's using this platform to show people
I had the choice between life and death
and and she chose the former and she's
using this platform to celebrate and to
sing and to bring joy into our lives and
I just can't say enough great things
about we love you Michelle as the Los
Angeles chapter president of the seal
fan club it is my humble honor to
introduce the leopard who I still
believe a seal
[Music]
I stand seal we know I say it loud I say
it proud if we needed more evidence to
prove to you why this is sealed the
leopard you know he talked about jamming
with a pack of misfits if you're a fan
of seal you would know that he was in a
British funk band and a blues band in
the 80s he also used the word free and
we know if you're a fan you've listened
to his 2008 album soul he has a song on
there called free I'm gonna point out
another clue we saw in the package it
was a newspaper headline that said slow
jams performs on the White House now
slow jams Jamie Foxx there Jamie Foxx
and seal half performs together at the
White House and we actually found a clip
of that so take a look so I know you
probably already know this because you
are the president of the seal fan club
but the item the item we saw was a
camera and seal is a self-proclaimed
photography geek he actually is an
ambassador for the camera company Lika
and he's seen everywhere spotted around
by paparazzi holding his camera as well
spotted like what you did that and
finally our last performer of the night
gave us something different and
certainly put on the greatest show take
a look
[Music]
[Applause]
once again that's got to be queen
Adrienne by law and Haute and we've said
this since day one
the voice is just the number one dead
giveaway but I thought it was cute in
the clue package she goes Mita which
means look in Spanish it's a very like
colloquial phrase and Adrienne is so
proud of her Hispanic heritage and she
loves throwing in little bits of
Spanglish so I thought that was a cute
little nugget and I thought the item
gave it away there is no denying this on
the real actually took home the
n-double-a-cp award for the outstanding
talk series two years in a row she's a
host on that show it's her we have part
two of our Cheetah Girls reunion
happening soon I'm excited for it I wish
they would come out on stage together
and Cinderella so now that we've seen
every performer that's left it's evident
that the competition is stronger than
ever there is still plenty of guessing
to do on next week's episode when we
dive even deeper into clue packages and
performances and of course don't forget
to post your comments below and tweet us
who you think the remaining celebrities
are I'm at Charles Aoki and a Mad Deidre
Behar we'll see you next week we're
gonna eat some more pie now miss patty
sweet potato pie a 10 out of 10 mmm
cherish tooth
[Music]